ESPN's Scott Van Pelt go golf host
SportsCenter anchor lankey good with
about a 15 to 18 foot jumper and Scott
joins us now on the program from Augusta
is that true about Amen Corner it's not
how they came up with that yeah amen but
is that you're a few holes down the line
you get you get into a dive back down
there 11 12 13 um but it's uh it's it
it's you know it you know on first and
first nine second nine you show what you
shoot here
83 first day 81 second day yeah that's
better than most I actually brought in
my scorecards I brought in some photos
from when I played it it was over 20
years ago and a couple of couple of
shots there on 13 one on 12 yeah I'm I'm
I was tearing it apart they're a little
bit they were certain there was some
Aurora there were some roars when I was
playing there Scottie they Dan proved it
after I shot an 81 there yeah that it's
it's it's you know it haven't been here
it's special I mean we get guilty
sometimes you get therapy the language
and this and that but honestly it's a
place to put you in a state of mind that
really truly it lends itself to that
it's just there there's nothing else
like this place in sports
Cameron's awesome for a basketball game
fog al and awesome for a basketball game
Wrigley Fenway whatever your flavor is
but ultimately those are you know
basketball arenas and baseball stadiums
and there are many of them this is the
only one of these that there is and
there is nothing that even comes close
to approximating it so that's why that's
why you get the hush tones and the you
know the the the Nance music that you
all heard of this home there in pebble
it all of it makes sense it all goes
together do you want to do do a Jim
Nantz impersonation who doesn't okay
Seaton hit the music for Scott Van Pelt
and he brings us on the air at CBS
[Music]
hello friends alongside sir Nick Faldo
here in the butler cabin let's go out to
the action on azalea that's it okay I
got it settled what to tell you it's
only an eight yeah it's a three it's
bottoms and you go back and play defense
but I like how you went sir Nick like
you got to go Nick found on sir Nick
yeah there's the annunciation it's he is
a brilliant broadcaster as we know him
yeah he's got all these like these
little subtle gears where there's a
there's an enthusiasm and yet there's a
I mean it's hard to do it's a heart is
hard to it's hard to you know show the
enthusiasm while at the same time like
the voice goes down but yet you know
he's excited I want you to listen to
this is our leader in the clubhouse
James from Los Angeles and he went off
script a little bit this is Jim Nantz
preparing to go on the air at CBS
ubiquitous 19 gale camera there
thank you 45 seconds Fred Couples has a
supple spine the undulations curvature
just wow what do you think that this is
someone that's been a great deal of time
that gentleman
that gentleman a success that's
brilliant I wouldn't be but I wouldn't
even have dropped Azalea if I heard it I
would have why would I have even pulled
out the driver you know why would I be
bothered Fred Couples has a supple spine
right Freddy couple spine is anything
but some point God love me still out
there shooting numbers it's incredible
all right recap day one the the
highlight low-light or what speech was
speech was remarkable just that that
stretch where he just went five birdies
in a row and
there was a period there dan in the late
afternoon where it was absolute
perfection here where it got warm enough
it was really it was it was cool in the
morning it got warm the greens or maybe
a little bit softer and more receptive
as a result and there was not a breath
of wind and speed took advantage and
given what he's done here and he gets to
seven and she started thinking man he
might do that thing where he runs away
and he makes a mistake off the tee on a
tee makes bogey and he starts today with
a double and all the sudden you realize
I was kind of silly to think that we'd
be you know beyond it but the obvious
low-light was you know Sergio the man
made a thirteen and I mean I said on the
air and it's it's it's a bad golf joke
but it's like how'd you make a 13 when I
made a hell of a 10-footer and and he
had to I mean he had to make a long putt
to make 13 and afterwards I mean he said
without saying you know that what
happened was may be borderline unfair
because he just said you saw what
happened I I had a 13 and I didn't miss
a shot and the ball just didn't want to
stop and so I mean it's not the first
time that that's happened but again as a
man that you know that shot the kind of
scores out here that had them
reconfiguring the golf course dan you
know that you're just an inch away from
something awful happening and I just
thought it was incredible the last time
Sergio played I've only had a three and
it propelled him to a win and then the
next time he played it he had a third
team it disparities is rarely ten shots
on the same hole but now his daughters
named after the 13th hole not the 15th
hole right right because fire fire
swords a tough name to walk but Azalea
is okay so he had a 13 on 15 not a 15 on
13 okay I just want to make sure we had
a right now I thought Tony phenyl just
if that was another golfer if that was
Rory or Spieth or Justin Thomas it would
be the number one story not enough
people know about Tony Fino you know
unless you watched big break on Golf
Channel or something but it was pretty
incredible with what he did you snap
your your ankle back into place and you
shoot a four under there yeah I thought
it was awesome and he's such such a good
young
and and such a likeable guy who I've
enjoyed getting a chance to know over a
few years he's been out here playing and
I mean and he was in the butler cabin
and I asked him you know the doctor
question zero to ten what was it he said
I was a 10 it was excruciating he said
but I had to finish and I was just
incredulous I'm like why it was
important recon test and he said
something actually was interesting it
made sense he said I had to sneak her
out like can I make a swing even the
half swing with a wedge like can I do
that so he did finish but you're a
hundred percent right and I felt like it
was the story of the day you know out
you know it speaks one hear he's a star
and he shoots that score so that becomes
the headline because he's leading but
but for female to play and to play that
well and as I said you're batting a
thousand you played one round and you're
in the butler cabinet you know come back
on Sunday obviously that's when you want
to be there when when Jim's there with
the supple spine in the green jacket but
fee now is awesome he's a great guy he's
got a ton of talent and you're right his
I mean that I mean he pops it back into
place and as routinely as I don't even
know what the analogy is but he just was
like oh here let me get this pop I am
back on you go I was I was amazed yeah I
thought you did a great job I saw the
the interview live and I mean he's
loquacious he he was telling you that he
didn't know if he's gonna be able to
play or not but hey it's my first time
here and I you know I you you shoot a
4-under is pretty impressive we're
talking to Scott Van Pelt from the
mothership all right Tiger Woods is
playing in competition on Sunday if what
if he does what he did yesterday he
played well he missed about four putts
that he's been making all year round all
he has to do is play as well as he did
yesterday and he'll be in the mix
because he was again about three or four
putts away from being on the right side
of par and the other sort of golf II
thing to look at is the par 5 he didn't
birdie one par 5 yesterday jordan Spieth
was six 5-under par on the par 5s
yesterday so Woods has got to play the
par 5s better just make cleanup a couple
of more you know short cuts and he'll
he'll be in the mix and I think he will
be yeah I always tell these guys when we
start talking about the Masters I said
you got to win the par-5
because if you win there uuugh everybody
has to you gotta kill the par fives
there and if you don't then you know I
think we'll look back on who's winning
and who's not and you're gonna see
people doing damage on the card box well
especially when there's guy like look
look at the look at the people like
Dustin Johnson or Baba or Justin Thomas
it's it a long way or you can do it
there's a constant way you can lay up
and just be a great wedge player make
birdies but you're a hundred percent
right whatever you do you've got four
really good scoring opportunities on
those holes you have to birdie them and
also I think Dan history will tell us
you cannot make a thirteen on one of
them I don't think that that has ever
worked out thirteen is not in the not in
the recipe book when's the last time you
played Augusta it's been it's been many
many many years I got a chance to walk
with the the late great Jim Huber which
was yeah and he you know of course was a
great broadcaster for so many years and
but it god it's been I don't even know
it's been longer than fifteen years ago
and there's a there's a member that's
been kind enough to invite me out the
schedules never worked and it's been a
couple of times that I said no and I was
told subtly you know I've never had to
ask more than once and so I have failed
in getting out here again but hopefully
hopefully someday again and I'll shoot
for those scores years down what uh
what's the nightlife like down there you
know they say suggests a national it's
happened it's uh it's actually it's
quite it's amazing because it's this
week there's an incredible hospitality
on like the highest end we are we're
with our friends from from wheels up and
tried to the project private aviation
game they throw a big shindig last night
I actually introduced Kerry Nicholas to
the crowd I he's the king of the he's
the king of the the Masters GG Jack's
grandson that made the hole-in-one
he's up there on stage playing guitar
and singing and oh it's a whole it's a
whole lot of middle aged guys on expense
account that have had way too much
bourbon that want to take pictures it's
a treat it's a John Daly
John Daly set up shop there oh sure
oh sure JD's just parked there at
Hooters signing something it's true
JD just just sets up shop on Washington
you know parks the bus signs stuff and
you know he's living his best life this
week when are you on today I mean you're
always on Bell's okay oh yeah exactly
yeah as van der Rohe right once told the
red light as always all we come on the
air but you know they're doing
highlights and updates to all morning
long on SportsCenter which is fun it's
nice to be able to just give people a
small taste of what it is they want
which is just to see some golf form out
here so you can catch those highlights
between now and then and we come on at 3
o'clock general right a legend did you
ever did you steal his stuff back in the
day is that how you became who you
became yeah I know Earl Earl was doing
that on headline sports and we thought
headline yeah yeah but nobody nobody was
taken what Earl was dishing out I wasn't
gonna steal it because I didn't think I
could pull it off yeah man Earl right
Hey Thank You Scott great to talk to you
thanks for the text earlier this week
yes indeed you're my man I'll talk to
you soon all right Scott Van Pelt for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]